ja so weit also der
cdu-parteivorsitzende da sachen die zahl
noch etwas besser aus mittlerweile ist
ziemlich klar dass die spd vorne liegt
und eigentlich auch den
regierungsauftrag hat ich begrüße ganz
herzlich heute abend peter altmaier hier
läuft den bundeswirtschaftsminister
herr altmaier sehen sie das anders als
ich oder ist es nicht so dass der
stärkste dann auch zunächst mal die
regierung bilden soll wir sind wir sind
natürlich alle enttäuscht dass wir so
stark verloren haben vor allen dingen
denken wir auch an all diejenigen
kolleginnen und kollegen die ihre
wahlkreise in folge dieses ereignisses
nicht mehr gewonnen haben aber gezählt
sind die stimmen wenn alle stimmen
gezählt sind das ist demokratie und
deshalb warten wir was der
bundeswahlleiter uns heute nacht
verkünden wird das zweite punkt ist wir
werden jetzt gespräche führen zwischen
allen parteien der demokratischen mitte
über die regierungsbildung und
die spd hat selbst häufig deutlich
gemacht in bund und ländern
dass es eben nicht darauf ankommt wer
die stärkste fraktion ist und dass es
darauf ankommt wer eine koalition
zustande bringt die eine stabile
mehrheit im parlament hat und ein klares
programm
helmut kohl hat er einmal 48 6% oder 76
und trotzdem hat helmut schmidt damals
eine koalition gebildet mit der fdp
obwohl beide parteien deutlich schwächer
waren ich glaube was wir jetzt erleben
ist dass es eine absage gegeben hat an
eine linke konstellation weil die linke
so schwach geworden ist die leute wollen
keine linke regierung es gibt eine große
wahlbeteiligung das heißt ein riesiges
interesse an politik das ist beides
positiv und jetzt müssen wir zeigen dass
wir über die parteigrenzen hinweg
imstande sind verlässliche politik zu
machen die neuen herausforderungen
anzunehmen
und da sehe ich die cdu csu in einer
vernünftigen position
es gibt nicht wenige auch in ihrer
partei die sagen das wäre zum beispiel
mit herrn söder anders gelaufen sie
haben ja damals auch gesagt lasst uns
söder nicht
letztlich wirklich an dem kandidaten lag
es an einem einzigen lachen oder wo
verorten sie diesen niedergang ich habe
ich habe ja dann seinerzeit aus meiner
meinung keinen hehl gemacht und keine
mördergrube aus meinem herzen aber ich
finde dass heute abend nicht der
zeitpunkt ist die inhaltlichen und
personellen fehler im einzelnen
aufzuarbeiten wenn man acht prozent in
einer wahl verliert wird man darüber
sprechen müssen was die gründe dafür
waren er gibt es waren analysen die uns
vorliegen werden das werden wir in den
gremien diskutieren aber nicht heute
abend und nicht in den nächsten tagen
wenn es darum geht dass deutschland eine
gute regierung bekommt die imstande ist
dieses land zu führen 16 jahre angela
merkel und dann so eine klatsche heute
übrigens auch in den beiden
bundesländern die heute gewählt haben da
muss doch was passieren bei der cdu es
kann doch nicht so bleiben welche
reaktion schlagen sie voller personeller
art erneuerung wie soll die aussehen zum
einen ist es so dass wir in den letzten
tagen deutlich aufgeholt haben von
ungefähr 20 prozent in umfragen auf
knapp 25 prozent bei den hochrechnungen
jetzt zum anderen ist aber auch deutlich
geworden dass uns viele wählerinnen und
wähler ihre stimmen nicht gegeben haben
insbesondere jüngere bis zu den grünen
gegangen sind und insbesondere ältere
die zur spd gegangen sind damit werden
wir uns beschäftigen wie mit allen
anderen
personellen und inhaltlichen fragen auf
aber eben nicht heute abend ich glaube
der respekt vor dem wählerwillen
gebietet es dass wir zunächst einmal
abwarten bis alle stimmen gezählt sind
und uns dann in ruhe zusammensetzen
armin laschet hat ist aber auch schwer
gehabt er musste zwei wahlen bestehen
die märz freunde haben nicht mehr so
richtig für ihn gekämpft im osten
desaströse abschneiden der cdu und dann
markus söder ich habe es nicht für
möglich gehalten dass markus söder
dann so nach tritt wie er es getan hat
waren das nicht auch ursächliche gründe
dafür dass wenn das eigene lager
zerstritten ist sich der bürger sagt
warum soll ich die denn noch wählen ich
habe eben mit blick auf armin laschet
gesagt dass wir jetzt nicht die stunde
haben für personaldiskussionen
ich sage aber auch mit blick auf markus
söder dass markus söder in den letzten
tagen einen großen beitrag geleistet hat
dass die union diese trendwende
geschafft hat das bayerische ergebnis
ist nicht so schlecht ausgefallen wie in
vielen anderen bundesländern
die union kann nur gewinnen wenn sie
gemeinsam politik macht und gemeinsam
vor die wählerinnen und wähler tritt das
ist die große herausforderung
dass wir deutlich machen das ist mehr
als eine zweckgemeinschaft sondern es
ist eine gemeinschaft die auf werten und
inhalten beruht vielen dank wenn man das
mal in münchen hören würde da warten wir
mal ab was in den nächsten tagen
passiert das war peter altmaier der
bundeswirtschaftsminister und damit gebe
ich zurück zumal anna maria